Male 1: In the last few videos
we looked at the final version,
the Declaration of Independence
as it was approved of.
Here it seems like we
have a very not final
version of the Declaration.
Male 2: What's really
amazing is they go through
five drafts at least of the Declaration.
It's wonderful to watch
how each of the drafts
changes. You have this
committee of real people.
Jefferson and Adams and Franklin are all
part of that committee. Jefferson is using
a lap desk, one of those
little things he invented,
so he could stand up or sit down
and write this in a little
room on Market Street.
Then he shows it to Adams
and he shows it to Franklin,
very deferential, he
said, "With your broadened
view of the world, Dr. Franklin, perhaps
you can make some suggestions."
Male 1: Franklin and
Adams could be his father.
Male 2: Right, right. Jefferson's only 33.
Really, really young.
You have Franklin and
Adams, Franklin's hitting
70s then, and very
much of a father figure. But you see real
people working together in these rooms on
Market Street in Philadelphia,
trying to craft this document.
Male 1: Yeah, yeah, and you see it here.
This looks like someone editing a paper.
Male 2: Which shows you how
important it is to edit,
in a way. Those of us who
are writers and editors,
we like the fact that
you should really quibble
over each word. These
are words that matter.
For example, you can
see they put in a little
phrase right here, "separate
and equal station."
In other words, America's
going to become a
separate nation and an equal nation.
That word "separate and
equal" actually goes
down in American history
with some resonance
because it's used for a
while to defend segregation.
Even when they get the
words almost perfect,
they have a resonance that
they have to be careful about.
Male 1: Do you think they realized when
they were writing it how important this
document was going to be?
Male 2: One of the
amusing things is this was
not considered the most
important committee
to be on in June and July of 1776.
In fact, John Adams thinks
he's already written
the great document of American Revolution,
which is a document
written in May asking the
various colonies to get rid of their Royal
governors because we
were going to break away.
So Adams is quite willing
to let Jefferson write
this draft because he
thinks that this is not
the most important of all the documents.
Male 1: And on some level,
to defend Adams a little bit,
that does seem like a
big deal. This was in
May of 1776 he writes once
you're getting rid of your
Royal governors you really
are separating yourself.
Male 2: And they've already
had a vote to be independent.
So this is just a document,
"let Facts be submitted
to a candid world,"
"the opinions of mankind ...
they should declare the causes."
This is really just their
public relations document.
But, the reason it turns
out to be so important
is it's so beautifully written, it becomes
the American creed. When
they get together in
these rooms and edit
it, suddenly they say,
"All men are created equal."
This becomes not just
a propaganda document,
but a mission statement
for who we are as a people.
Male 1: And to some degree
the power of poetry.
They could have said
these exact same things
in very terse and ...
Male 2: This is why it
was so good Jefferson
wrote it because Franklin
is a very good writer,
but he's a very simple, plain writer.
He writes Poor Richard's Almanac,
"A penny saved is a penny earned."
He's one of the first
Americans not to write
in a very flowery way. John Adams' letters
are very beautiful, but
they're kind of pompous
and orotund and self important.
You have a beautiful poet in Jefferson,
but as we're looking at
this document on the screen,
even he benefits from some good edits.
Male 1: This is literally Jefferson's
handwriting we see here.
Male 2: This is Jefferson's
handwriting on the
first draft. It's in
the Library of Congress
if you want to go see
it. The final document
is in the National Archives,
about eight blocks away.
It's really wonderful
to look at all of these
documents, especially,
I mean what do you see
here where they edit the
great second paragraph?
Male 1: "We hold these
truths to be self evident."
You mentioned earlier that before it was
written, what, "sacred and ...
Male 2: Undeniable. Yeah.
They're using the word
"sacred" for the truths
when Jefferson writes the
first draft. To me, if you
look at the backslashes,
the dark backslashes there, those are
Benjamin Franklin's
backslashes I'm pretty sure
because he used a
printer's pen and he was a
publisher, so he used that
sort of backslashes to
cross things out. He writes
the words "self evident."
One of the things is we
historians never fully
know. Carl Becker, who
was a great historian
of the Declaration, he's
the one who said that
that was probably Franklin's
edit. For me, I've spent
a lot of time in Ben
Franklin's papers, which
were at Yale University
Library. To me, it really
feels like his handwriting.
So we assume that it's
Ben Franklin who takes
out "sacred" because he
doesn't want "these truths"
to be based on religion.
He wants "these truths" to be based on
rationality and reason.
Male 1: So once again
it's not only the style
of the crossing out, this is in line with
Franklin's personality and beliefs.
Male 2: Franklin was somebody who had read
the great thinkers of
the British and Scottish
Enlightenment. That means
John Locke, David Hume.
David Hume was a person
who came up with the
concept of "self evident
truths." A self evident
truth would be that all
bachelors aren't married,
as opposed to a more contingent truth like
Philadelphia is smaller than London.
Male 1: Kind of in math an axiom.
Male 2: An axiom,
exactly. The fact that two
plus three is five,
that's not something that
has to be further proved.
These are somewhat
"self evident." That's what Hume does and
Franklin loves that. Franklin
loves Isaac Newton, too,
because Franklin is a
scientist. He believes that
there are laws of nature, of nature's God,
and that there are certain
self evident truths,
so he doesn't want the
word "sacred" in there
because that kind of
seems like divine right
of kings. God's the one
who made these truths.
He's saying, "no." As
we've discussed that whole
paragraph, it's about
rationality and reason
getting us to those truths.
Male 1: Right, but they
also do talk about,
as we talked about previously,
there's a balance here because
they do talk about "created equal."
Male 2: Well, let's look.
Tell us, what do you
see there? This edit,
it says that they were
had certain inherent and
inalienable rights. You see
John Adams, and we're pretty sure that's
John Adams' writing,
not just because of his
writing, but because of the concept.
He was a little bit
more religious than the
others on the committee. He says,
"They're endowed by their
Creator." He puts in that phrase
"by their Creator" with
certain inalienable rights.
It's a balance. It's a balance between
rationality and reason,
which is self evident,
and divine providence,
this notion that we're all
children of the same Creator
and therefore we're all
endowed with certain inalienable rights.
Male 1: Yeah, this is
really amazing. Just to
realize that they were human beings
kind of forging through this.
Male 2: Yeah, they're real
human beings who were probably
arguing just like you.
Jefferson gets really upset
at someone; not at Franklin
and Adams, but other
people start editing
it. Franklin tells them
this wonderful story
about when he was a young
tradesman in Philadelphia
and somebody had a sign
about selling hats and
everybody tried to edit
the sign for them. Franklin
said, "That's why I've
never been on a committee
that's going to have
a lot of people editing what I write."
But, those of us who are
editors, we kind of think
those edits actually improve the document.
Male 1: Yeah, it seemed like it turned out
a pretty good result.
Male 2: You know, you
don't get much better than
"We hold these truths to be self evident."